- I would Netflix with Rocket,
because I feel like
Rocket would probably be
a lot more quiet during a movie.
I think that Starlord just talks,
like he just doesn't shut up.
- I need a roommate that's clean,
so I would have to say an Avenger.
Don't hate me, guys.
- I'd rather be with the
Guardians of the Galaxy.
When I sleep, I snore and my
snore's more of a whistle,
so they understand that and
they'd put tape over my--
nevermind.
- Guardians of the Galaxy.
I don't know any of the Avengers.
(laughter)
- First of all, I would
never ever wish to live
in a studio apartment in New York City.
If I had to be stuck there,
trapped there like a rat,
I'd want it to be with the Guardians,
because I love them dearly.
They are my friends and family.
- Tights and I'd have a dance about.
It'd be okay.
- 12-foot long cape.
I'll take anything but tights.
I actually stopped doing a movie one time,
because I was going to
have to wear tights.
- I would like a cape.
- Yeah, a cape, it's so much cooler.
- Yeah, they're really cool.
- Can you fly with a cape?
- Yes.
(laughter)
- With the cape, I'm hoping
that I can wrap around,
I like scarves, and I can
just kind of cool it up.
Cuz tights are just, just not good.
And just all the little kids
would just be traumatized.
- I think that Gamora
would be a little nicer.
I think my sister's still very volatile.
- I'd rather bring Gamora
home to meet my parents.
But I'd rather take Nebula out on a date.
- Gamora's much nicer.
- Nebula is, she would just kill everyone.
- Yeah and--
- Or she would stay in a corner, and not--
- Yeah, like sulking, and
being socially awkward, moody,
and then she'll like kill their pet.
- Nebula has all sorts of little tools.
Y'know, her arm can come out
and become like a little hedge trimmer.
So yeah, Nebula.
- I'd dig, I'd hang out with Rocket.
We've become pretty
good pals in this movie.
- Starlord.
- Netflix and chill?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm gonna choose Starlord as well,
because I think that we would
want to watch similar things.
- Mantis!
Are you kidding me, she's so sweet.
- I'm gonna have to go with Mantis.
Mantis is like, she can touch
me and know when I wanna stop
and get a coffee and that kinda stuff.
- I would go with myself.
(laughter)
- Doesn't make sense.
- I choose Mantis.
- Oh, Mantis.
She's sweet, she never talks back.
(laughs)
I'll just go with Mantis.
- Baby Groot, c'mon.
We'd be building like coconut trees
and pissing off all the
animals on the island.
- Baby Groot's a better dancer.
Oh yeah, the entertainment quality.
I mean, Thor talks way
too much, first off.
Baby Groot, you understand
exactly what he's saying to you
when he talks to you.
- If you don't want to be stuck
somewhere with Baby Groot,
then you're just a
horrible, horrible person.
- Baby Groot.
You might be able to get off that island.
Thor ain't gonna do much
with a hammer, I don't think.
- If we're being practical about it,
you have to choose Thor,
but like just for enjoyment
and cuteness, I mean, Groot.
- Maybe you can put yourself on the tree
and you can swim with him.
Like a boat.
- Yeah, you can make a raft
- (laughs) A raft, that's
the word I was looking for.
(laughter)
- I'm not into S&M here,
I would be massaged with Thor's hammer.
- I'm more of a thunking kind of guy.
I think the hammer thing is good.
- I guess, if you're, that's
like stuff you used to play
when you were a kid,
do you wanna suck snot from a?
I'll go with the tickling
rather than the hammer.
- I'm gonna go with Thor's hammer
and also because that Hemsworth
is quite a good-looking man.
- It's kinda sexual, right?
Like, massaged with a, I don't know.
- (laughs)
Well, I don't know where
you mind just went.
I was feeling a little
unnerved by the tickled,
with the Wolverine thing, cuz like,
you're just gonna get cut.
How gentle can he go?
Because if he can be really
gentle, then I'd choose that.
- Who the hell thought of these questions?
(offscreen chatter)